so i'm standing there using a veteran
battlefield tactic where you blowtorch
an enemy tank to see if you can trick
the driver into getting out so you can
steal it and like a total noob they did
and i'm like what nobody falls for that
anymore and then it hit me there's a ton
of new players in battlefield this year
welcome seriously we're really happy to
have you battlefield is this amazing
janky sandbox and we're gonna have some
fun but first there's a lot to catch you
up on in this video there are a lot of
things battlefield players have learned
over the years and some unspoken rules
you should know about and vets help me
out here because i'm sure i'm gonna miss
a few all right hit that sub button slap
that thumbs up or whatever you do to
that thing and let's get to it number
one
c4 if a sniper won't quit you gotta do
them like that there's this unspoken
rule in battlefield and that's to mess
with people who refuse to play
objectives especially if they just want
to sit back and snipe we know it's a
hell of a lot of fun to do and it's okay
if you want to do it from time to time
but if you do you're going to see two
types of behaviors from veteran players
if you're sniping too much someone on
your team might walk up and drop an ammo
crate right in your line of sight that's
their way of telling you to play the
objective but a little bit more fun is
if an enemy sniper is caught doing the
same thing i mean sure you can counter
snipe and plenty of people will but
there's no greater insult than creeping
up behind an enemy player gingerly
planting c4 next to them and then
basically doing that thing star-lord did
to thanos
[Music]
number two jeep stuff this term was
coined at least in my memory by the
amazing battlefield friends and if you
haven't seen that show
go watch it
this is something that's gone between
being a bit of a joke
a bit of an annoyance and then also kind
of accepted by the battlefield community
but if you see a tank you need to jeep
stuff it that's where you attach c4 to a
vehicle and drive it into the tank then
you detonate it
i mean sure you can see for a tank the
old fashioned way but jeep stuff is just
so much more satisfying
[Applause]
[Laughter]
number three while you're at it stick
things to other things battlefield is a
sandbox and there's a lot of stuff that
will stick to each other this has been
on and off through the series so you
never know if it'll work or not
sometimes it gets patched out but it
totally worked in the 2042 beta to do
this i approached a transport vehicle
from the hood for some reason if you
jump on the back at least in the beta it
gets wonky and tries to buck you off you
can then drop metacrates and ammo crates
on the roof or the rear truck bed then
you go drive around dispensing ammo and
health but there's even more bad company
2 was notorious for players attaching c4
to the uav which you can do again here
toss c4 onto casper's recon drone and
have fun sending that little package of
death to enemy snipers that won't quit
or even use it against vehicles
and speaking of the drone number four
they are misunderstood through
battlefield history the poor mav and
things like it have been notoriously
underutilized their main trick is not
well known it's not really spotting
although they are good at that casper's
drone is no different a lot of people
never find out drones can fire emp darts
those darts can destroy other casper
drones and disable vehicles temporarily
including tanks and transport planes if
the spawn beacon winds up in 2042 we
haven't seen it yet but it's in every
other battlefield game you should
destroy those too if you really want to
flex disable a vehicle and then try that
blowtorch trick i talked about in the
opener number 5 swap class kits so you
can't do this in 2042's all-out warfare
mode but you'll probably be able to in
portal you can do this in every other
battlefield game so we're going to cover
it here classically in battlefield when
you down an enemy player you can grab
their gun and also swap to their class
kit that's pretty clutch if you find
yourself in a bad situation like up
against a tank without a launcher or if
your recon buddy gets drilled and you'd
like to set up a spawn beacon before
counter-sniping
in 2042's all-out warfare you can still
grab an enemy player's primary weapon
and ammo which is pretty helpful because
ammo seems to run out pretty fast when
you're on a tear now while we're here it
seems that in 2042 you can also swap to
a different ammo type to get more ammo
unless that's a mistake and gets patched
either way keep this one in mind if you
find yourself in a bad situation without
the right class kit to take care of it
number six be careful where you spawn
battlefield's not a series that holds
your hand very much if you spawn on a
team member in a fight you might die
real quick if you spawn near an enemy
tank and you don't have a launcher good
luck to you if you spawn at your base
and there isn't a vehicle have fun
running now you can always redeploy
using this menu but that typically loses
tickets for your team
number seven dynamic entry there are
plenty of buildings that aren't
destructible in battlefield 2042 but the
ones that are you can get through their
walls using a rocket launcher or c4 we
did test grenades but that didn't seem
to work if an enemy team is holed up
inside and aiming at the door it's time
to make your own door
number eight spot a lot all the time
spotting is how you let your team know
what's going on in battlefield when you
click on an enemy player with the right
button they get a little carrot over
their head that means everybody else can
see them spotting is basically just how
you let your team know what you're
seeing plus you get points for doing it
in 2042. it really helps your team out
or at least warn them that a tank's
coming located hostile
120 degrees 250 meters
number nine the friendly pistol request
so we noticed there wasn't a request
wheel in the beta to let your team know
you needed some ammo it's gonna be a lot
harder now with specialists to even know
who to get ammo from but if you realize
someone has ammo and you need it the old
way of communicating is to shoot a
pistol at your teammate if someone is
doing this to you they're probably not
being a dick they probably need
something that you have give it to them
and you get support points hopefully
contextual callouts where a request
wheel will get added in the final build
i need some ammo
number 10 ear bleeding sound this one
should be quick every battlefield game
has a sound setting called war tapes it
gives you the most raw sound experience
and i'd highly recommend you at least
try it once
all right battlefield is not just a game
about ground soldiers there's a whole
bunch of vehicles going around and we're
going to talk about those next number 11
get into a moving vehicle easy vets know
this one but for new players simply hold
x when a friendly vehicle approaches you
you don't have to time it at all as long
as there's a seat open and you're
holding x you'll get it this is how you
see people getting into moving vehicles
helicopters and doing the rendezook and
things like that
number 12 when getting out make sure you
aim the right side towards the enemy
literally classically in battlefield you
get out of the vehicle in the direction
you're aiming if you're in a turret or
the side you're sitting on if you're in
a seat this has changed from game to
game i tested it a bunch in the 2042
beta and it seemed mostly still true
although you would often exit left if
the vehicle had a seat in the middle
like a transport buggy that means if
your vehicle takes a bunch of damage and
you need to bail quickly turn your right
side towards the enemy and use it as
temporary cover rather than get out
directly in the path of fire you can
also do more vehicles than you think you
can shoot through their windows which
people often don't expect or you can go
prone and shoot under them
13. treat vehicles like soldiers
speaking of cover you wouldn't stand out
in the open as a soldier and you
shouldn't do it with a vehicle either
there are plenty of things in this game
that shoot rockets that can get you move
cover to cover with vehicles no matter
what you're in tank or helicopter if
you're in a helicopter don't fly over
excessively open spaces where you can't
duck behind a building to stop rockets
from locking onto you 14. mind games
there are two main mind games
battlefield people like to play to get
you to ditch your vehicle the first one
is if you're in a helicopter and you
hear this sound
that's someone locking onto you with a
rocket launcher now your first instinct
is going to be to drop your flares right
away but that's a trap the soldier on
the ground will probably keep locking
you up hoping you'll dump your flares so
they can then fire when you can't stop
it flares distract rockets so instead
dive for nearby cover to break line of
sight and then come back and hunt down
whoever it is only dump your flares on
the second tone which means a rocket is
actually coming at you
as another indicator the menu here will
also turn red when that happens the
second mind game is the one i opened
with savvy players will do things to try
and get you out of your tank or vehicle
and then steal it from you go repair it
and come back to haunt you so don't
automatically jump out of your vehicle
if you're about to lose if there are
lots of enemy soldiers around who can
steal your ride and fix it up sometimes
it's better to go down with the ship
savvy
15. don't forget to swap seats vehicles
can have a wide array of weapons and
other tools in different positions and
there's no reason you need to stick to
the driver's seat in a transport vehicle
it's often safer to switch to the top
gun than to get out and fight another
player on foot you can also use your
regular class weapons from the passenger
side tanks in battlefield typically have
a 50 cal on the roof and because it's
higher up it can be fired over large
obstacles and used very effectively
against helicopters
number 16 you can repair from the inside
this is an old trick for helicopter
teams but you can go to the door slot
and use a repair torch to repair
helicopters and transport aircraft
mid-flight it's really good at racking
up support points and keeping you in the
air longer
number 17 don't be a dick and steal the
chopper if you need to get somewhere
high to camp the entire game in snipe
have the decency to not steal your
team's only helicopter just to crash it
to get there there are some god tier
pilots you might be taking it away from
but to be fair there are a lot more
vehicles in 2042 so at least don't do
this too much or make sure there's other
vehicles for people to take 18. use
vehicles creatively in the 2042 beta i
was able to jam up an enemy doorway with
a transport vehicle and make it a lot
harder for the other team to get out of
that hallway and fight us i also saw an
enemy team drop a tank on a rooftop as a
matter of fact c4 launching vehicles on
top of buildings is kind of a thing in
battlefield
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
number 19 the repair tool is a tanker's
best friend if you do like driving a lot
the repair tool is a must in keeping
your vehicle healthy or just be a pal
and repair other players tanks get them
support points number 20 battlefield is
a sandbox you should experiment with it
a lot this is going to be a rapid fire
section i messed around a ton with
different specialists and here are some
things you should know mckay can grapple
just about anything including his own
supply drops zip lines and rockets
launching into orbit mckay can also kill
with his grappling hook
boris can place his turret a level above
him and reap the benefits of spotting
and improve lethality without sticking
his head out specialists can be great
outside of their roles folk makes a
surprisingly great sniper since she can
quickly heal herself from body shots you
have a knife apparently hold down melee
to pull it out and get stabby
battlefield finally has a proper
parachute system with three states air
control shooting and freefall the rocket
launcher makes a fantastic sniper rifle
you can make your own cover by firing a
rocket into the ground you can hide in
these blue crates in a pinch and you can
kill yourself with your own vehicle drop
and hopefully somebody else
and 21 if you can resist don't sweat the
unlock tree it ain't perfect but
battlefield does a better job of
balancing weapons over time than many
other games that's both good and bad
good because balance bad because it's
hard to feel overly excited about
incredibly adequate guns don't make the
mistake of burning yourself out grinding
up to that gun you want because its
handling is probably just totally
reasonable in fact many of the starting
guns in battlefield games are often some
of the best and you can just put your
time into mastering them and unlocking
their attachments battlefield is a
massive sandbox and i'm sure i missed
plenty of other things battlefield
players know help me out in the comments
below and for tons more videos around
battlefield 2042 head on over to
gamespot's youtube page the full game is
out in november and we're pumped thanks
for watching
[Music]